and now we have news in the battle
against autism as you know one out of
every 88 children in this country
diagnosed by the age of 8 and the best
hope
early detection today the top autism
experts in the nation announced they
have broken new ground they say there is
a simple way to find a red flag and
children as young as six months
something parents can detect and
something that could change lives
here's ABC's medical editor dr. Richard
Besser babies can tell you a lot without
speaking a word
Benjamin six months old I'm gonna do the
head lag test watch his head as I close
arms up he comes right up with his body
that's normal first age but this is head
lag and today the startling news at six
months it could be the earliest possible
sign of autism that's been Jason in
research video look again see how his
head stays back pediatricians have known
head lag like this can be a sign of
developmental delays but today's study
is the first to connect it to autism
because early intervention is key
doctors say it could make a huge
difference in treatment we don't have to
wait until after the first birthday
until first words aren't emerging we can
go ahead and take action now to have the
child develop better dr. rebecca linda
tested a group of babies who had noticed
occipital babies at high risk
seventy-five percent of babies with head
lag like ben ended up diagnosed with
autism at age two and without that clue
Ben's parents would never have suspected
it I would have told you going into that
day that everything was normal when we
see these kinds of indicators that
development is disrupted so early in
life we really have a huge advantage to
help children's brains connect
themselves in a healthier fashion
families can start therapy sooner that's
what happened with ten with intensive
speech and occupational therapy here he
is today I have a very loud boisterous
wonderful three and a half year old son
Ben is now considered only borderline
delayed an amazing glimpse of what early
intervention can do beginning with a
simple test good job oh it is great to
see the difference it can make but why
is their head lag do they think in a lot
of autistic kids
we know that children with autism have
delays and a lot of their motor
development sitting walking running but
we don't really know the why and I won't
throw it parents to panic here because
you're telling me in your practice you
see head leg and it does not necessarily
mean autism exactly I mean every parent
who sees this who has a six month old is
going to do the headlight testing and
that's a good thing but I see children
all the time with this by nine months
it's gone and they developed normally
but don't ignore it you want to make
sure that your doctor if we see this
they're following up on it okay big news
tonight thank you rich